run unless this is the run right before
the tournament you ask me you know who's
gonna the run but there's a lot back
then who woke up today it's like I I
don't
I cannot call it like I mentioned
there's gonna be two stuff to call but
once we get closer I'll make a
prediction once we're in Grand Finals
how about that well we have two players
up I could go safe man I was only off by
one man I didn't pick the winner by a
pick second place save that for finals
baby anyways we're gonna go to the
matchup right now it looks like rich six
is gonna go pick Maxie's epic eye width
Sophie see how this is gonna play out of
course they are going at it here in the
center of the Ring nice getting all
those hints again keeping that
aggressions epic I get the GI the follow
up here good block of course oh yeah he
went for it the run up he's expected you
to stay buried and go with the micro
tuck as people like to look out for
throws or quickly get any pulse again
run and for that willow top play six is
beat instead it's gonna be the sidestep
makes the follow up simple guy striking
first blood but it gets dumped it's got
something to give this in this part oh
yeah
when she says continuing onward here
gets the nice damage again with the six
six feet this guy is just pop it away
and eventually that's gonna add up on
the guard games as well rich six he's
gonna have to be careful blocking all
those is again 616 unblock the clash
will he try the GI afterwards do that he
was gonna get a reaction out of his
opponent but now buddy give it to the
dangerzone is every guy starting to
fight back they're both in the yellow
follow up around there
try not to choke things up you know Oh
light kick going up try this
alright let's up will this time stand up
eat the shoulder and take the crown
follow up
zero and again he's at the Rennes he'd
have to be very very careful I was gonna
work here six beans they're coming out
and such as you already know such an
interesting mechanic there right because
you see a guard gate flashing the game
is telling you that hey if you keep
blocking right you're gonna get poking
for free but at the same time you can't
just become offensive went back C is the
oppressor this this character just goals
well that's the thing too I feel like
you know what players are in the red it
kind of gives any open invitation for
his opponent to attack him and that's
kind of what people want they're like oh
this guy's gonna want to use this very
nice tracking move to be able to create
an opportunity to get more damage on but
never mind never mind here we go the
follow-up hello for the mix-up yeah
absolutely I respect it yeah because
which takes all the second dater that's
gonna whip punished with the critical
edge and look at this rich sticks gonna
take that first match the Fist of Fury
[Music]
and one of the better ones I feel like I
feel like the guy that wrote that as
well lights or a bad light - I have a
few very possible I don't know man I
think to be as well you have to be like
special it's gonna be this person for
however long they were there anyway back
to the magic stick picking up where you
left off where did his life for go but
it's somewhere it's yellow now I I can't
tell color is just everywhere Sophie not
getting a chance to play one player game
she tries to go to the sky where ristic
says wait a minute down here wait a
minute guys really gonna have to start
turning things up this is again a race
to two matches looking for will punish
opportunity but doesn't want to jump us
anything too fast a swift kick Tammy's
at stampers no matter what getting the
stunt on the counter following it back
to back this table cashes out all the
damages rich sticks these [ __ ] doing
such a great job of fighting those
initial hits to stun to be able to get
the full follow up on the bobble here
and that's the thing is like every time
you try to step in find an opportunity
except for that time right there nice
able will add that big six feet oh great
for teams in order to get out of that
throw I would have thought through
already but very possible look into
itself alright take a peek seven seconds
on the clock will somebody activate so
I'm gonna have to do with there's no
time left
yeah you have to bet it all they're
choosing not to activate it's gonna eat
the swift kick to the head and depakote
it's big time trouble down the game
ground but like you said this means
nothing at all it's over yes two meters
true this might be that's it oh this
might be the turn has it at the wall too
what's he gonna do with it it's gonna
ask him to try this looking with time
until he eventually says yes oh yeah
still going for it the persistence there
wasn't land that big hit
oh here's a ground this is it he is in a
red zone he's gonna have to be very very
careful how he works from here on out
right this tops up to take the
opportunity he's gonna charge it up but
instead runs directly into the
elimination rich six the one who broke
the cold yes karma came back to me and
came back to what amorous very
impressive placing here from zeph guy
getting in our top five but his
tournament life is gonna fall short here
start to see the hearts break a little a
little extra pep in his step right it's
like okay still alive I look
exceptionally well no bored down to the
wire stuff last minute cooked clean on
to the next foot
it's still form article is our top four
is three Axl players and it's sane right
yes oh my god that's quite the pick
right yeah I mean the odds are in your
favor but at the end of the day it's
it's a it's a single-player game so
teammates are not they will all fall one
way or another one person will advance
to our great Invitational with the eight
other seventh world champions gonna get
an inside look at exhale check Alicia's
heart beat after this short break